can as a tenured professor in your
mid-40s what made you think that you
could change careers well this is
America and you can do whatever you want
to do it's one of the great things about
this country and I was what I was doing
was very related to a career I'm in now
it was developing stories developing
writers and of course teaching a number
of things that I no longer teach like
classical literature and Italian
literature and I do miss I did do miss
that part but it was basically an
extension of what I've been doing all of
my life which is developing stories
analyzing stories publishing stories
helping people publish stories and now
getting stories produced into movies so
it's all united by storytelling I had no
idea which world was sort of the bigger
world of ideas the world of academia
that I had been in for 17 years or the
world I went into and I discovered that
the world I went into was really the
world of ideas because it's a world in
which people are tracking ideas across
continents to find out who owns the
rights to a story they're you know they
they pay lots of money to acquire the
story they use the least they used to
pay a lots of money and they spend
millions of dollars to turn the story
into a movie and they're fiercely
competitive about the world of ideas
it's the motion picture business is the
jungle of ideas and it's survival of the
the best idea and the best business
people I always say it's it's called
show business for a reason it's not just
about show it's about the business of
how stories get developed into movies
that the whole world can see I'm hoping
we can go back to maybe right before you
made this transition into wanting to be
in film was there something that
happened was there just a time in your
life in your mid 40s where you just felt
like you know what
I want a new challenge you know that's
good question because it's my I
reflected on it all my life since then
and it was actually provoked by my
receiving tenure I actually belonged to
a untenured faculty committee against
tenure and one day when I was a
Fulbright professor in Bologna Italy I
got a telegram from the Dean of the
faculty at Occidental College telling me
that I'd received tenure in my absence
and my reaction to it was not very
understandable to my friends and
colleagues I I became deeply depressed
for about a year and it took me a long
time to figure out why I was depressed
and it was because I had really never
asked to be in this golden cage where
nothing can happen to you it was like
the most secure place you could be and I
realized at the time that my father's
chief value in life was security he was
a child with a depression and security
was all important to him and I had to
admit to myself that it wasn't that
important to me I never worried about
being secure I published lots of things
and I was in demand as a speaker and
just never had to worry about it
and what my value was was freedom and I
didn't feel freedom when under a
structure where you had to behave a
certain way and you had to know a year
in advance that on the week of October
12th you'd be teaching book eight of the
Iliad and that it was wonderful to be
teaching the Elliot but to have two to
know that a year in advance you're gonna
be somewhere I now live in a world where
I don't know where I'm gonna be tomorrow
literally and and it's complete opposite
it's the world it's a free world and of
course I realized as I got older that
freedom is as much an illusion as
security both of them are illusions but
it was my illusion security was not my
illusion and so I've lived with complete
insecurity but with the freedom to
express myself creatively in every
possible way which is what the film
business allows me to do and so that was
very exciting to me do you ever tell
people that that if they're looking to
be in a creative pursuit whether it's
being an author or screenwriter actor
that security is something that will
probably not be part of what they'll
encounter and it okay with that
absolutely I mean this is not a career
to wish on anyone you have to have a
burning desire to do it and you have to
be willing to sacrifice anything to do
it and to persist despite every setback
and I can tell you that this is a
business in which a career in which this
never gets easier I don't care how many
movies you've done the next one is going
to be the biggest challenge you've ever
faced the world changes all the time
it's been changing ever since I've been
in it which is around 30 years now and
it never gets any easier and it never
gets any more secure and you know even
if you had windfalls and lots of money
you would put it into your next you know
your next project because people in this
business believe in what they're doing
that's their most important common
belief you can see it at the Academy
Awards you you hear the stories as they
receive rewards that they never thought
they'd get or have been waiting for a
lifetime for they all have one thing in
common the ability to sacrifice what
everyone else considers the most
important things in order to achieve the
dream of getting the story told to the
whole world and that's Nestle the great
thing about the career there's no limits
to it it's infinitely challenging it's
constantly challenging there surprises
every day and it's completely
unpredictable I'm almost thinking of a
sales position like door to door where
you have to just suit up and and go on
your
you're in work your farm and it sounds
like with this industry it's it's an
everyday sort of you have to be that
person sort of drumming up leads and
things like that yeah it's a completely
self-starting business you hear
repeatedly from actors and from writers
and from everyone that being represented
by a agency does not really help because
everyone said I always get my I've
always gotten my best jobs by myself and
I hear that from musicians and from
every member of this business that they
get their own work and and suiting up is
every morning is putting on your brain
and telling it that it's got to be happy
and go out there and it doesn't matter
how bad things are in reality you have
to put on a happy face and I have gone
to many meetings that I absolutely did
not feel like going to because something
had just happened that was a setback and
I just thought I want to stay home lick
my wounds but I go to the meeting and it
always turns out that those meetings are
the best meetings that you go to and
when you walk out you think thank God I
went I mean what would have happened if
I hadn't gone and that that is suiting
up that is definitely a kind of a
nightly encounter to put on your armor
and go out there and you're working with
people who are doing the same thing and
that's part of the exhilaration of it is
that you know that the person sitting
across from you may have had worse
things happen to him in the last 24
hours
but he's still there on the job and
putting on a happy face and getting it
done it's it's very deceptive and
seductive when people come here for the
first time especially clients of mine I
I warned them that they will be
experiencing what's called the
development dance where everyone will be
extremely nice to them and extremely
positive and then they'll never hear
from them again and that's because
people are doing their job and their
their job is to find out what this
person has to offer the world and if
it's extremely exciting which is rare
very rare then you'll hear from them but
most the time it's not extremely
exciting and exciting enough and or it
doesn't fit the agenda of the of this
person's company at the moment they have
something too much like it in
development or they have a boss who does
not want to do that particular kind of
thing etc but their job is to be the
best audience possible for any story
that comes along it could be a dramatic
story that people will you know that
would attract audiences and so they'll
they'll be happy and then in the meeting
and then at the end of the meeting you
know behind the back of the person who
came to the meeting they'll make a
decision about whether to pursue it or
not and that's what you're up against
so you are like a door-to-door salesman
I always say there's a great black
Florida in the sky that has every know
you'll ever receive in your life written
on it and finally a yes at the end of
the nose and the only catch is you can't
see it so what do you do you you go
through the nose as fast as you can
that's the only way to deal with that
black board and that's what successful
people do in the business they just keep
getting those nose until somebody says
yes